kuhglocken als wahrzeichen des
widerstands gegen die schweizer corona
maßnahmen ruster nahe zürich wir wollen
wissen warum protestieren so viele
menschen in einem land das mit so wenig
maßnahmen durch die krise geht
mit einer wohl für sie betrogen wurden
wir sind betrogen wurden von a bis z und
ich traue einfach den ganzen quatsch
nicht mehr ab und ich glaube es mit
grundsätzlich nicht dämpfen ich habe
mich sagt 16 17 jahren nicht mehr impfen
lassen also ich finde das überhaupt
nicht locker der umgang mit der korona
politiker sind die grundrechte die uns
weggenommen worden sind und das ist ja
keine impfung das ist eine gentherapie
da sind die freiheit richler die
ländliches brauchtum für ihren protest
benutzen
da sind menschen die an verschwörung
glauben corona leugnen
da sind aber auch viele junge studentin
die sich gegen das kobe zertifikat also
3g regeln wären mit dem coro zertifikat
mit unserer gesellschaft maximal
gespalten menschen dürfen nicht
bearbeitet nicht mehr studieren die
familien zerrissen als fenster zerstört
nach dem interview wird die stimmung
immer feindseliger wir werden beschimpft
bedrängt behindert ein wütender
demonstranten beschädigt unsere kamera
keiner greift ein
wir müssen die dreharbeiten abbrechen
ihr protest verschärfte spaltung in
einem land das in der krise bislang auf
freiheit auf eigenverantwortung statt
einschränkung setzt erst als die
infektionszahlen ende august wieder in
die höhe schnellen erst als kliniken um
hilfe rufen zieht der bund die reißleine
erst jetzt gilt in innenräumen geimpft
genesen oder getestet schon das ist in
der schweiz fielen zu radikal aber wie
radikal sind die maßnahmen gegner kurz
vor der demonstration treffen wir die
gründer der bewegung maßvoll maßvoll
heißt für die beiden alles bedingungslos
öffnen kein impf druck weg mit den
masken ich dort haben
nirgendwo nirgendwo
wie kommen sie damit durch also wie
schwierig ist es
mittlerweile lebe ich dass viele
menschen ermutigt
hat eine kleine sich auch keiner ab weil
die maske ist mehr disziplinierung als
wirklich etwas gegen dieses virus
sie werben für violette zonen erklärt
nicholas rimoldi in denen die korona
regel nicht gelten sollen die beiden
nehmen uns mit zu einem gastwirt am
rande von zürich der bei sich so eine
maßnahme in freie zone ausgerufen hat
sowie der spaltung bekämpfen
da übertreibt die regierung
nicht meint die us regierung schon das
ist hochfinanz so dahinter staunt die
welt steckt dahinter sind immer das ist
eine verschwörung und ich dann sehen uns
von gewalttätern vogelsterben in
arkansas vor lästigen auf trifft sie
distanzieren sich von gewalt aber die
verschwörungstheorien lassen sie stehen
wir wollen ja selbst auch nicht
zensieren das ist dann immer so der
sprecher hat sich eine selbstzensur und
das alles gelten was dann zum beispiel
die auch aus bewegung schaden können
freiheit geht jetzt vor finden sie aber
die menschen die sterben durch corona
muss man es dann in kauf nehmen für die
freiheit wie gesagt der gesundheitliche
schaden der angerichtet wird durch diese
maßnahmen ist viel größeres sucht das
virus
die intensivstation am klinikum bis zu
90 prozent ausgelastet auch wenn die
infektionszahlen rückläufig sind
dieser coup patient ist mitte vierzig
ungeimpft hängt an der lungen maschine
müssen
er bekommt nicht genug luft muss gedreht
werden
in den letzten wochen
sehen wir vor allem junge patienten mit
weniger vorerkrankungen die aber eine
deutlich schlimmeres krankheitsbildern
deutlich schlimmere infektionen haben
also keiner der patienten die jetzt hier
konkret erkrankt sind sind geimpft
das personal ist erschöpft und wütend
über das zögern der politik die proteste
den personalmangel kann sein wenn dann
die das personal fehlt dass das ganz
anders ausgeht mit
eventuell verteilen folgen für den
patienten die impfquote der schweiz
zählt mit 55 prozent zu den niedrigsten
in westeuropa
mit einer im tram versucht man in zürich
die vielen skeptiker zu überzeugen es
sei höchste zeit für mehr druck findet
der gesundheitsdirektor im grunde
genommen ist in einer pandemie eine
gutmütige diktatur eine gute art und
weise die pandemie zu bewältigen weil
manchmal braucht es auch
zentralistischer entscheidet umgesetzt
werden
damit macht er sich nicht nur freunde
[Musik]
der machte 68 63
die impf teams müssen mittlerweile von
sicherheitskräften geschützt werden
was müssen sie sich da anhören
es beginnt mit einfachen worten wie sein
mörder wir verteilen giftspritzen und
hört auf mit wir bringen dich und deine
familie
[Musik]
und die politik ringt um eine antwort
vor allem die wählerstärkste
nationalkonservative svp viele
parteimitglieder denen die impfung ab
bundesrat maurer immerhin teil der
regierung lässt sich mit maßnahmen
kritikern mit den freiheits trichtern
fotografieren und der rest der regierung
schweigt
durch fehlende abgrenzung blüte hass
sagt einer der immer versucht zu
verstehen und jetzt rote linien
überschritten sieht christoph sigrist
fahrer autor präsident der gesellschaft
für minderheiten und das machen wir in
der pause geht das diese frage ob du
dick bist oder nicht sich praktisch nie
in einem raum hinein geworfen mir wo die
semitische und rassistische äußerung
plötzlich mit einer neuen nährboden
es ist ein kleiner radikaler kreis der
die spaltung verschärft die sonst so
neutrale schweiz bringt um ein
gleichgewicht zwischen dem schutz der
freiheit und dem schutz der gesundheit